gas prices had already hit an all-time
high before president biden announced
the u.s would ban oil imports from
russia so what could that mean for our
economy and russia's war on ukraine
joining us now is halima croft managing
director and global head of commodity
strategy at rbc capital markets good
morning halima how are you doing
good morning
now um we need to know how important the
russian oil is to the u.s and u.s energy
market to russia can you kind of shed
some light on that
sure i mean russia is not a major
exporter to the united states we
basically get less than four percent of
our oil from russia it is hugely
important though to countries like
germany germany takes 34 of their oil
from russia 32 of their gas comes from
russia 50 of their coal comes from
russia so a country like germany is
uniquely dependent on russian
commodities but what the united states
has done is essentially signaled that
sanctions pressure is going to grow on
russia and so that is creating anxiety
that we're going to lose additional
russian exports russia is one of the
world's largest oil and gas exporters
and what we're seeing right now i'm in
houston at the moment is we're seeing
major oil and gas companies western
companies saying we're not going to do
business with russia they're cutting
their ties with the country shipping
firms will not take russian crude banks
will not finance the trade and russian
commodities and so you have a situation
right now where we're seeing russian
exports fall dramatically because of a
self-sanctioning process we're
potentially set to lose three to four
million barrels of russian oil exports
because energy companies are saying we
do not want to run the reputational risk
of doing business with russia and
funding vladimir putin's war machine
helena we are already seeing gas prices
rising we know that will continue and
the president has said he will try to
counter how can the u.s
counter that and how quickly might
people see that impact at the pump
i mean the concern really is you know if
this war gets worse if we have a
prolonged conflict we have to prepare
ourselves for this higher price
environment for gasoline the question is
will we see further reductions in
russian oil exports that would put more
pressure on prices now one thing that
the bright administration is trying to
do is get additional oil on the market
so pay very close attention to what is
happening with countries like venezuela
the white house sent a delegation to
venezuela over the weekend there's talk
that sanctions on venezuela could be
lifted and if venezuela and barrel start
coming to the united states that is a
potential replacement for russian
barrels but again the volume that we're
talking about from russia potentially
coming off this market it's going to be
very difficult to fill that in the near
term saudi arabia does sit on additional
barrels the question is can we get the
saudis to put more barrels on the market
and there's always a question about what
about the u.s oil and gas industry the
u.s is a major risk everyone knows oil
and gas producer
us is going to grow this year but if we
want to see larger and larger volumes
out of u.s producers it's going to take
time putting drills to work means you
get additional oil in six months and
that's why there is this real concern
about this near-term price pressure
well president biden says he wants to
ease the pain for consumers that could
take up the six months so we'll see how
the next coming weeks and months
follow out thank you we appreciate you